we've got food shortages we've got
inflation at record highs we've got gas
prices at record highs we've got
immigration especially illegal
immigration at record highs we've got
the first major war in Europe since
World War II we've got
lots and lots of problems nothing is
going right for Joe Biden and yet Joe
Biden insists that this is his strength
and I agree with what chairman Powell
said last week that the number one
threat is the strength and that strength
that we built is inflation
the number one
threat is the strength
and the strength that we've built is
inflation now I'm
I think that might be true I think I
think fact check true on it then the
number one threat is the strength okay
what is it strength isn't a threat right
what do you okay what do you mean by
strength you're saying the strength is
that you have built is inflation well
you did build inflation you are one of
the principal drivers of the inflation
crisis we have right now and that is the
number one thread so I guess he's
telling the truth probably unwittingly
probably because the teleprompter was
too difficult for him to read or
something but I think Joe Biden actually
may have just accidentally said the most
honest thing he's ever said in his
entire career
yes this is the threat this is a major
threat to the country disproportionately
to people at the lower end of the
socioeconomic spectrum and it's a big
threat to his presidency and it's why
the Democrats are Running Scared here I
think it's why in large part they tried
to shift away from the economic problems
to a cultural issue like abortion and
then abortion didn't work for them then
it turned out that was actually a loser
too so now they're trying to shift and
say Republicans want to get rid of
contraception they're making this
argument they're saying if we have a
rule rovy way then they're going to
overrule the Griswold decision which
found a constitutional right to
contraception they're gonna they're
gonna Outlaw interracial marriage
they were truly grasping at straws
because they know
that this is a loser they know that the
midterms right now unless there is
widespread voter fraud
which there might be is a great new
movie out by Dinesh D'Souza called 2000
mules I actually haven't seen the whole
movie yet so I want to wait to comment
on it until I can finish the movie but
there is you know as we've said
especially on this show as we've said
from the very beginning since election
night 2020 lots of questions about that
election lots of weird stuff lots of
obvious violations of the law in certain
States and how the election was
conducted huh it's kind of that's not
good if we don't get our election
security under control then we're not
going to it's not going to matter how
much momentum we have going into the
midterms or into 2024 but assuming that
we can get that under control which we
have in certain States at least uh it's
going to be a blowout
assuming nothing changes it's going to
be an absolute blowout for Joe Biden and
for the Democrats I think a lot of
people right now are looking back on
those Trump days those days of
Republican rule quite fondly
I think I think people want Trump back
if not in the white house so probably
that too but if not in the White House
certainly on Twitter which is why Elon
Musk is now saying this is really
breaking news Elon Musk is saying he
will he would gladly reinstate Trump's
Twitter account
I guess the answer is that I I I would
reverse the Perma ban I would say I'm
not I don't own Twitter yet so this is
not like a thing that will definitely
happen because what if I don't own
Twitter but my opinion and Jack Dorsey I
want to be clear shares this opinion uh
is that we should not have permabads
okay great
then why is he doing this
one because it's the right thing to do
Elon made this point explicitly said I
think it was morally wrong to ban Trump
but he's also doing it this is a real
message if you're not a true Rock ribbed
conservative constitutionalist Patriot
whatever word you want to use
at least let me appeal to your
self-interest right now
the issues that conservatives are
running on are winning issues
having the ability to speak freely on
social media that's a winning issue the
libs have a losing position on that the
conservative said winning position
pro-life pro-life or pro-abortion look
at that vote yesterday in the Senate the
pro-life side is the winning argument
here
okay
the restricting immigration that is a
winning argument poll after poll after
poll shows it
the Stop Printing money it's sending it
to all people all over the world and
actually maybe Focus your resources at
home that's a winning argument
stop letting Dr fauci govern the country
get rid of all the stupid coveted stuff
that's a winning ARG it's all the
conservative arguments are winning even
just from yourself
interest
you should be siding with the
conservatives if you're in the middle if
you're a squish if you're an independent
it is in your interest to side with the
conservance for goodness sakes even
Whoopi Goldberg agrees on this point
especially on the point that Elon just
made Whoopi Goldberg on The View she is
a very left-wing lady she just said yeah
if Elon wants to put Trump back on
Twitter that's probably the right thing
to do
listen Donald Trump wants to be on
Twitter if people want to listen to him
fine
because that's what it is that's where
we have said to people you have the
right to say whatever you want to In
This Place we've Let It Go and when it
suited us it was fine and when it
doesn't suit us it's a problem
so right Wolfie you tell him that's
right yes if people want to listen to
Donald Trump who is by the way who is
not some Fringe radical extremist danger
he's a former president of the United
States for goodness sakes he's been a
celebrity for 40 years he's a very
well-known cultural figure if people
want to hear from him they should be
able to hear from him it's not just
crazy right Wingers who think that a lot
of liberals think that too a lot of
Democrats think that too that's why the
Democrats are getting crushed in the
polls right now
glad you liked that clip now ring that
smash like that subscribe do the clicky
thing make sure you get all the Michael
Knowles show updates you can also go to
Apple podcast Spotify Stitcher Google
Play subscribe to the Michael Knowles
show leave a five star review leave a 10
star review if you can we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]